[Music]
so
there i go
[Music]
the
spiral you're going to do is going to
pay attention to his hands after you get
to the elbow okay
so when i go over here
i am paying attention
to how that hand
goes into this lock here
this first lock here okay
so you you don't want to keep turning it
this is the emphasis on the elbow
go rewind the film
the elbow did his job
and i come off the elbow back into the
hand so yeah i have this one here
you see
so your grip can't keep turning
so we'll go back and i'll show you and
you can get smooth more smoothly
into
the pin
right away you see that
let's do it again
right in right into it immediately okay
whereas
you've been in la la land and you're
used to your
choreography that falls
and you have this kind of stuff like
this you see
and this part from here
is a big assumption
so if you now focus on where his wrist
was in space
after
the kazushi
it goes
right into the
technique you see
okay so we'll just smooth that part out
you should be able to get it right away
okay
here we go
go again
it says look how much that hand comes
over it comes way to the left of you
okay
okay let's go let's do it again
oh let's go again
okay same very similar thing all right
so this this is the uh the
aikido uh kind of stuff so you're not
you don't have a marshall application in
mind you see so you're like um
let me keep taking pressure off of this
you see so instead of the elbow control
we we pull on the hand
you see get it off
you have to think a little differently
so
my elbow control
is
not
going to be about taking pressure off by
pulling this hand off okay so we're here
it's my body superior engine to him
you got it
my hand
is almost staying in place
and i'm going to take my
pelvis turn my pelvis unite my four
corners to it and that's what turns him
and you can see how the hand barely move
in space
and that's how i'm right
there right away
whereas
i can't unite my four corners i can feel
that i'm getting
disconnected
and so what we do is we pull it off
you see
but now
yeah you're not going to get there again
okay
again in lava land you get there but
you're trying to arrest someone you're
not getting there they're out they're
gone okay
so hold pop you have to use the right
engine
here pay attention how much does the
hand actually travel in space that's
what we're looking at
doesn't travel in space
okay
let's try it again
okay the
the reference point of the second
law
is that energy
is going to pass through
this way on his arm
okay
into the technique so
in
ikkyo i'm not
on this lever thing windmill
and i'm on the outside
okay
i'm going to come around from the inside
so when i got here
i should be in a position where i can
attack that elbow
so i'm going to pass through
in this energies this way
so the final pin position of ekyo you
already have it
you already have it where the two
uh the wrist and the elbow energies
making the triangle you you'll have it
through the technique
we'll have to let our partner out a
little
so we don't dislocate
go ahead and take your chemi you move
your body
okay but you can see
it's here
and it's not here it's going this way
this way
moving around this way
i'll let him out
you see
got it
i'm doing the technique
i'm inside and i'll let it up
where do i stand
i'm gonna let him out
where do i step on the last step
this way
we're gonna make a turn we're not gonna
come back out this way
we're gonna make a turn
this way that's where i let him out of
the technique
[Music]
this way
how how much that way so you could have
gone
over here
into this position
not over here
around
coming
all here
on that step if i let go
that's the law i don't let go
but i'm already on the inside against
the elbow
now let mayuka out
not too much dude
and
this goes this way
that's what brings his hand
at his head level
and now i do
the quad mechanics for all those pins
okay
that means my
pelvis
and my energy
drops
so early training
requires you to be able to
attach
for example
your wrist your elbows and your
shoulders to
your
pelvis
okay
and then
an overall architectural assumption
of
the art
the tactical architectures of the art
is there's a x value for the amount of
power you can generate
and then a y value for the amount of
power you can take away from that person
okay
but there is a value it's not any old
value okay it's not your value and your
value
okay so
to reach the x value of my power is very
related to
that pelvic utilization that's going to
make me reach my power potential
versus my arms shoulders elbows
wrists are operating independently
you're going to be way you're going to
be sub x okay
so when i go here i'm not going like
this
you see that you see how my elbow came
out
this hand is locked in the relationship
with my pelvis
the only way he's going to make this
hand go here
right is the pelvis has to fail
then a y value
he's pushing he's pushing he
he's not going to he will not be strong
although he's way stronger than me he
will not be strong enough against that
pelvis
but i can do a y value too i could take
pressure off of him
but you don't want to just go by value
so
he's here boom pelvis is in a
relationship with my elbow wrist and
shoulder
and i'm going to take some of his
pressure off with the y value so that i
can go back into my x value
you see
not going
keep trying for y
sum
so here
you can go
y value
y value but you're going to give up too
much why that
instead
use your pelvis
you want that hand over here
turn your pelvis
do you see
then you want this hand over there
move your pelvis
move it
you want this these fingers to go
towards his head
drop your pelvis
you want to break his arm drop your
pelvis
so when you come around to the technique
and you do the last part
my pelvis is moving
not my hands
i come down
this last part
drop it just like you did in all the
other pins
i'm not going like this
i'm not going like this i'm not doing
skeletal alignment
wherever i'm touching
i just drop it
okay so
this is where the magic tricks come in
you're like
doing it with your finger
you see that
but
this joint
not my finger strength
is connected
to my pelvis
so all i got to do
is turn my pelvis it's the same power
it's the same power
just like here
you can do
it was never my hand
it's my pelvis
do you think
it's a trick
because you thought
do you see
but it was never that
it's just dropping my pelvis
do i come around
same thing here
you're used to
or
you can just
try your problems to it he tries to lift
the elbow
doesn't matter it's no different
you'll understand okay so
about
you when you come around
to here you're like oh oh but if you pay
attention
it's all disconnected
there's slack
such that either your pelvis moves
without your arms or your arms move
without your pelvis
do you see that and that's why you feel
so powerful
instead
you gonna connect
here when this turns
just hand turns
got it i never actually moving my hand
through space
which means my hand never actually
moving him through space
this part of my body is
much more powerful okay
let's try